information importante sur les sorcières
elle existe les sorcières ne sont pas de
vraies femmes ce sont des démons qui ont
une apparence humaine
dans chaque grande ville dans chaque
petit village elles vivent parmi nous et
s'il ya une chose à retenir c'est que
les sorcières déteste les enfants
mesdames j'ai un plat
une boue de suffire à transformer un
enfant souris et ensuite on extermine
brasser l'air
serra on extermine à les rats on sait
faire on sourit c'est ensorcelé grobon
serra
[Musique]
première par ici c'est toi mon garçon au
nos vaches et veaux ou un doigt les
arrêter on vous laissera pas mettre en
oeuvre votre projet démoniaque et qui va
m'empêcher mien
n'importe qui tu es
ou à quoi tu ressembles
nous vous ne seriez pas en train de vous
promener avec une souris sur vous à tout
hasard une souris pourquoi diable je me
promènerai avec une souris
[Musique]